>>> TODAY WE ARE ETI
TLOEN
OUTDOORSPEEOPLE
WHO ARE FULLY VACCINAT
SISINIS.T  HEALTH
OFR
ENE CO
HIS MILLIONS O>> BLL SNORTDGMENT
HOW COULD YOU?
TH'RM BEHIND THE
CAUSE.
THATHE SHOULD BE
ASKING OF THEM IN RETURN.
IT'S OUR JOBO BRUSH THEM BACRTH
BON.E THE SOCIETY WE WERE
SO THE NEXT TIME YOU SEE SOMEONE
IN A MASAL
THBIO NOT HESITATE
ASK POLITELY BUTMLYOU PLEASE TA.
MF>> HE IS TELLING HIS TO G ME
CONFRONT PEOPLE WHO ARE OUTDOOR
O OWING AN
PRCDN MASK
FAR HAVE ALREADY BEEN
HARAED.
MIT TA AI-HARASSME, T HE DID WH
TRUM
>> TS THO WITH TH NO LOR SOCIA
ES OR GONTS
IF THEY DARE LOMEY WILL BED BYS
>>F YOSK EMT , G.
ABLY NOTRE IS 'S RUD
Y
CLR  WHEN IT COMES TO
MSD HIS FAMILY.
>> I CAN'T
STBEGET YELLED
EMPLOYER AGREED, QUOTE,
THE VIOLENT THREATS AND DS HIM
AN A COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE FOX SAID.
,
BECOME FAR TOO INT
DIENTS OF VIEW AND CE
CLEAY GHT THE NEED, SPND
INCLUSIVE TIONAL
AND NOTET X IS
ON
B'SOR AST
CAO WANTS THE VACCINE CAN GET T
POINT TH
MANDATE MA
>>NYINCIENTIFIC JUSTIFICATION?
OTHER THAN THE S THA
MASKS WORK.
OTHER THAN THEALF OF IS STILL N
VACCINATED.
T
FUE OP
STUDENTS ARE TO TAKE MY WORD FO
IT --
>> NOWH THD IN SIGHT, WE
HOPE
>> WE HAVE TO KEEP UP THE FIGHT
>> AND IF U CAN, GET
VACCINE.
>> AMERICA, WE'R
TOGETHER.
>> I DON'T HAVE
WEARING A MASK.
ESPECIALLY IF ITE CAN GO
TO A BALL GAME DEF
GRAND GRA, MOM
DOZENS OF RESEARCH PAPERS HAVE
PROVED>> SO AS FOR HIS CRUTCH T
EN ARER HE ACTUALLWAAMERICANS IN
OF VACCINES. THE VACCINEEFFECTI.
NO
RECEIVED TCI MASKS OR
AYBET DOESRKEY'RE SIMPLY NOT TE
THAT.
WORK AND RE
N'VA AEDDOES HE ACTUALLY WANT HO
FINALLY -- I WN AUSTIN A FEW DA
WITHOUT A MASKD ING OUTSID
STARAT ME, LM TH
CRAZY ONE FOR MOTT HAVING A MASK
ON, MEALASK ON,
I SHOULD BE LOOKING AT YOU AND I
L LIKE I WOULD LOOK
MAN HUGGING A TEDDY
BEAR AND HAVPAER
HIS MOUTH WHILE STREET. EE WITH.
H ANTIBODIESSKHI SAY
GROWN MAN EXPOSEN BLIC.
THAT'S DISGUSTING, PUT IT A WA
PLEASE.
>> SUGGESTION?
TTA GAME.
E
ILONNDFAWHEN AN SON DECIDES  HA
REMEMBER, ER'S W. T U
CO U IT, FOX MTHINK THE PRIGHT.C
HF ASMET TELL
VIHIS VIEWER THE
WANT TO HEAR AND SOMETIMESE
MISREADS THEM.YOU CAN SEE THAT R